let's go to Aiden from the DC area Aiden
welcome to the program what's going on
hey how you doing uh I've been watching
your show for years probably since 2017
2018. thank you
um just kind of happened upon the
channel today and noticed that you were
live I don't really have any particular
question but
um I I work at a restaurant in DC and uh
I was actually driving around DC
um on January 6. and I'll tell you it
was like when they finally sent people
to DC from Maryland it was the most
amount of police vehicles I've ever seen
in my life oh interesting
um but I work with some
um
deniers of the 2020 election and like
even to this day like we've talked about
it all and they're just like like you
they still don't believe
that Biden won and I I guess my question
to you is at this point you know what
what can you do to deprogram people I at
this point I don't know I we recently
looked at a poll where something like uh
it was either 40 or 55 percent of
Republicans still believe that Trump is
actually the winner it's it's
dangerously delusional and honestly I'm
sort of at the ready to give up phase
where my thought process is we just need
enough voter turnout to make them
irrelevant and of course that's a lot of
voter turnout that you need but if they
still believe it at this point what
could we possibly show them that would
change their minds and in fact I would
put it a different way they weren't
really given any evidence to get them to
start believing this stuff so I don't
even know that evidence is what's going
to get them out of it
correct yeah I'm kind of in the same
boat
um you know my problem is there's
there's so many of them you know it's
it's easier well just ignore them and
get enough votes but we're talking about
tens of millions of people here who
believe this stuff you know if you say
it's half of the people that voted Trump
you're talking about 35 ish million
people who believe that the guy who lost
actually is the guy who won I don't what
do you do what do you it's you can't fix
education quickly I mean these are
adults they're not in the in the school
system anymore to learn critical
thinking and media literacy
um there I I'm at a loss quite frankly I
don't know yeah I see I'm a server so I
come across a lot of people uh from both
sides and I I've had some pretty
aggressive
Trump supporters come in that I've had
to serve really like do they try to talk
politics with you absolutely uh how does
it come up
well uh usually it's it's some jab at
Biden though that Brandon guy you know
with our taxes excuse my language but
you know something like that
and it just kind of shove it down your
throat mentality wow and then how do you
respond
um I honestly just try to agree with
them because you know like as as lightly
as I can and just avoid the subject
because you know serving them I don't
wanna
you know offend them in any way how did
the mega people tip
um if if they don't think you're a
Democrat uh pretty well I'd guess is
that you think that that's a factor
I I do I actually do have you had not
with everybody just just I would say
more uh the extremists have you had
situations where a customer gleaned the
fact that you were not a Maga guy and
that your tip suffered as a result
not that I would directly say like that
it happened but um I've never given it
away that I'm not you know for either
side because she brings it up wow
sounds complex I'll have to say
yeah I I just try to avoid confrontation
I completely agree at the same time with
with people I work with that I'm more
close to and I care about when when I
see that they believe something that's
inherently false and they're just on
this side of crazy and I'm you know I I
just
can't think of what to do or say to
bring them back to reality reality yeah
now if you figure it out other than I
haven't figured other than politics you
know everything's great but when it
comes to that it's just like they're in
a different land I completely agree with
you Aiden thank you for the call I
appreciate it yeah keep doing what you
do David take care how many times have
we heard stories like that from servers
at restaurants it's a quite quite a
situation
um people in transportation Uber drivers
we hear it from everybody quite frankly
all right everybody we're going to take
a quick break we will be back with more
Friday show right after this